Nora wrote in hey David who are the most
famous fans and followers if the David
Pakman show that you know of this this
is a kind of a complex subject me
because number one I don't want to
necessarily name people that are
followers but not fans or whatever I
also don't want to leave people out yeah
it's an issue because a lot of people we
don't know
vaguely aware of the show is different
from someone who watches the show every
day right you and that's another issue
here's some people that I know have come
into contact with show content right
it's not just that they follow me on
Twitter but it's that like I have some
reason to think they're aware of the
show because they've either retweeted
content or commented on it or whatever
actor John Leguizamo wright-patt very
very impressed without former NBA
basketball player John amici huh singer
Duncan shiek are you familiar with
Duncan she was popular in the 90s he had
the song barely breathing that was
really pop that's all yeah that's Duncan
cheek oh boy that that's not the
reaction Duncan's gonna be looking for
on that one
no I'm kidding pat pat recognize the
song Roseanne Barr
yes he's familiar with the program 86
Omron now here's one that I I don't know
how familiar she is with the content but
Rosie O'Donnell follows that's huge I'm
a big fan of Rosie no matter what Donald
Trump said about her I like Rosie but I
don't know how familiar she is with the
content she follows me on Twitter I
don't know what about our former
fearless orange leader John Boehner John
Boehner follows follows us on Twitter
but again I I don't know that he's
really familiar with the content you
know for the most part he's been
following us since he was actually a
member of Congress and it's probably
staff that makes follow decisions I
don't know yeah and of course we have a
pretty impressive interview guest list
we have a short horn and John Kerry and
Roger stone and Richard Spencer bands
those are guests on the program yeah who
else I don't know I know that there's
people I'm forgetting here there's a lot
of senators actually who we've not
interviewed who can follow us and
members of Congress but those are those
are some of the names I I'm kind of
blanking on some others I think you
would rank
hi on the list and me like right I'm one
of the biggest names that is a fan of my
own program how sad is that that's
depressing
all right Nora those are those are some
of the people anyway and I know I'm
forgetting key people and I'm gonna feel
really really guilty about it oh you
know what Stu Brooks bassist for dub
trio and basis for Matisyahu yes Montana
basis for Tupac and The Fugees at one
point on on an album is oh no Don Lemon
follow you Don Lemon that's right Don
Lemon follows me and the show and and I
know that he's at least seen one of our
stories it was about him
banjos ago yeah yeah van Jones it's a
little dicey with Van Jones right now
but after all right anyway if you are a
well-known follower of the program and I
did not list you please let us know
because I think that would drastically
help our credentials on the bonus show
today we will talk about a new program
and you a project for Ivanka Trump and
Marco Rubio we will talk about smart
glasses that look normal
unlike Google glass and we will also
talk about a lawsuit against Walmart
over segregated beauty products which
ties into something we talked about last
week get the bonus show david pakman.com
slash membership patreon.com slash david
pakman show